Tommy Barav,
thank you so much
for joining 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you for having me.
It is so great to have you.
I can't wait to talk about
self-optimization.
So, you had a company
called Supertools
and you are a walking super tool.
And Tommy, over the next 20
minutes, I want to learn what
it means to be productive.
I want to learn what it means
to be self-optimized.
First things first,
I need you to stand up
because this is killer.
Just to stand up? Okay.
I'm wearing my pajama.
[laughs]
Yeah.
What is this?
It's a Zoom shirt so I can
so I can be elegant
be elegant while I'm doing Zoom calls,
but you know,
still feel comfortable
wearing my PJs.
So, yeah, you see
In terms of the angle,
you see only the shirt,
but actually, it's like
it's my PJ. I'm only
- Unbelievable -
- I'm working from home, so I -
Yeah my
Actually, my mom
I got it like to send
a shout-out to my mom because
she made it for me.
So yeah.
Unbelievable, unbelievable.
Okay, Tommy, first of all,
I wanna talk to your mom.
Second of all, let's talk
about self-optimization.
What does it mean to be productive?
Yeah, so for me to be
productive is probably to prioritize
and to do the stuff
that really matters to you.
So meaning that,
you know,
if you want a create growth
in your life,
if you want to achieve your,
let's say, goals, you need systems.
And by systems, I mean
you need mental models
and also technology
and digital tools
because it's like real
superpowers to really create
this compound interest of,
basically, self-optimization
or self-improvement.
So I really -
Why do we need that?
Because we go about our day
You know, we're all working.
We're working hard.
We're doing you know,
sometimes we work 12,
13 hours a day.
Why do we need to self-optimize
if we're getting stuff done?
So we live in a very, let's say,
hectic times when you have
so much information overload.
Some experts call it
the "attention economy."
So you have so many things to read,
so many things to learn,
so many things to,
you know, when you open
your email, you probably have
so many messages
that you need to go through.
But when you ask yourself,
"What really creates growth
around my life, around my"
you know, "what actually
makes me happy,
what actually makes
me a better person,
a smarter person?"
And probably
You know
So, think about everything
that you want to achieve in life.
This is not something that
you will find on Facebook
or you will find on Twitter.
This is something that
you need to work hard
and every day.
And this exactly the meaning
of compound interest.
Like every day
Like becoming 1% better every day.
This is something that
you can really achieve by
building your own systems.
And this is why I love
the fact that we are living
in a world that
you can create your own software
without knowing a line of code.
This is amazing.
This is like a great superpower
that everyone can take
and go above the noise
and become much smarter,
become more talented,
and more resourceful than ever
because they create
their own systems,
their own software around
you know your goals
and your desires, basically.
So, just to simplify it,
what you're saying is,
this notion that if we are
if we improve some aspect
of our lives by 1% every day,
that 1% is actually compounded
and actually,
after a hundred days,
we've actually improved
almost sort of 100% of ourselves.
And if we take the time,
and we use data,
and we use software
to think more critically about
what we do, and soon
you're going to show us some
of these insanely cool features,
then we're gonna be able
to improve with,
actually not,
and it's actually not that hard
to improve once you have the data.
And let's just start.
Show me what's on your
on your middle finger
on your left hand.
That's one
of the coolest things.
It's a beautiful ring but it's not
a wedding ring, right?
Yeah, basically, sleep
like I'm fascinated by ...
multipliers that we have in life.
And some of them are really easy.
This is like, you know
The fact that sleeping is so
important for so many aspects
of your life, and still, we are
compromising our sleep every night,
especially entrepreneurs,
especially founders.
I see many founders,
like you know, bragging like
They share with me the fact
that they are not sleeping well.
And they're not saying it as
like, to be
you know, as something that
You know, sometimes,
I'm hearing people like
proudly speaking -
- Right.
about the fact that
they are not sleeping well.
You know, "I'm working hard.
I'm not sleeping like
I'm sleeping 4 hours a night
meaning that I'm working
very effective
and very hard"
But the fact that busy
doesn't mean that you are
productive or effective
Right.
It's probably the opposite.
Like if you are not optimizing
your day, so you're probably
going to compromise your night.
And then, what will happen
in the long run
that you'll be less healthy,
less focused, less anything.
There are so many elements
that are affected
from our sleep,
the way we sleep at night,
not only the
duration of our sleep,
but also the quality of our sleep,
that I was amazed by the fact
that there are so many books
that you can read.
I think the book called
Sleep Wisely, maybe.
- Okay.
- I need to check it out
but I will send if we have
some notes on Facebook.
We can send some links
or the tools that
I'm going to share
and all the books.
A hundred percent.
A hundred percent. Yeah.
Yeah. Sleep Wise.
Okay. So, Sleep Wise is
Maybe not, maybe
it's Baby Wise.
Maybe I'm confused
with my Baby Sleep.
[laughs]
Okay. Yeah.
This is also important
but I think that
Everyone knows that
sleep is important
but not everyone are taking
not everyone are optimizing
their sleep and understand
how can it actually affect
their day because
you know this is our defaults
and we are living with them
and our body kind of adapts
but in a way, when I optimize
my sleep and this is why I bought
the ring because I wanted that
the first step to optimize
something is, basically,
observation and learning
the status quo.
Okay. Like a startup.
So the first thing that you do,
you're doing
like a market research.
You're checking
out a few competitors.
So, you're doing some research.
So, if you want to improve
your sleep, you have to learn
what is your current situation.
You have to do some analysis
work like to understand
and -
And that's impossible to do
when you're sleeping
because you're sleeping.
You're not actually aware
but this ring helps you
by giving you, I guess,
you know, a dashboard that says,
"This is how much sleep
you've gotten, this is where
you didn't get good sleep,
and these are your improvement
steps for the next day" Right?
Yeah, basically,
this is the web interface.
So, it's not very
it's not the best interface.
They have like an app that I can
share with the audience
as well, but basically,
you can see trends
around my sleep, not only
the duration of my sleep
but also some cool stuff
about cycles, like the stages
So, you need REM and deep sleep
in order to
really create a quality
sleep every night.
So, basically, it's around
30 percent of REM
and 30 percent of
deep sleep every night,
regardless of the duration
of the sleep, of course,
between seven to eight hours
is a good sleep.
Nine hours is not very good,
also, but you know,
I'm hearing a lot
of people like sleeping,
on average, four hours,
five hours a night.
And this is
you know, it's so
I don't have words
to say like how bad it is.
- I'm going to -
- You know, if you're
on your 20s,
so okay, it's fine.
Your body probably can adapt.
But you know, I'm like on my 30s
and I can tell you that after
I optimized my sleep,
like the fact that
It's a power multiply
to so many things.
Your productivity, to the
way you make decisions
to the way you actually
run your day,
Yeah.
to your happiness,
to your love,
to your
Everything is kind of affected
from the way you sleep.
It's not only duration.
I've heard this quite a few times
but Tommy, you're
I mean the things that you do
to optimize your day go
far beyond just the sleep.
So, you're
I mean you are literally
optimizing almost every
single part of your day.
So, I'd love to spend the next
Yeah.
thirteen to fifteen minutes
you know, let's go over
a bunch of the things that you do
to self-optimize because
I wanna learn myself,
and I think that anybody
who sees this is gona be
just fascinated to see
Yeah.
what's possible in the realm
of optimizations.
Sure. So, the first thing
that I learned from the book,
Atomic Habits,
is that it's not very useful
to define goals, to set up goals
and to set up
objectives for your life.
It's better to set up systems.
Right
So, if you want to do something,
if you want to become someone
Let's say, I want to lose
some weight, okay?
So, it's good to have
like an eye level goal
of what you want to achieve,
but it's better to have a system
that works every day.
It's much more effective,
and this is exactly
what I did here.
So, I created a system
called ...OS, which basically,
I have levels of things
that I want to improve.
And you can see it here.
So, the levels are reflection,
body, reading,
so I want to become smarter
by reading, seek truth.
I'm drafting stuff.
So, I love to write stuff,
I like to network.
So, I love to meet people
and I also love my family.
So, I want to also
So, every article that I'm reading
and every piece of information
I'm capturing in this space.
So, I have some levels of life.
And if you know Naval
So I took some inspiration
from his post,
his tweet storm around
that it kind of outlines all
the important stuff in life.
So, I just put it here and I
created some spaces around it.
- Wow.
- And basically,
Here, you can
inside of every pillar,
every level,
I have pieces of information
and inspiration that I took
from many people.
But here, on my ...OS,
basically, I'm managing
all my information here.
So, I'm managing my focus
areas like what I want to achieve.
This is basically my OPRs,
my personal OPRs.
I also have here some rewards.
So, for every OPR
that I'm achieving,
and for every goal
that I'm locking,
I'd get a
like I buy a gift for myself.
-Wow.
For example,
this one, I will buy like
this new magic keyboard,
this awesome magic keyboard.
So, this is sort of like
a reward system that
I created for myself.
And this is why I love
Notion and other platforms that
you can see now in the world.
They are letting no coders,
so people that don't know how
to code, they're letting them
build their own systems,
which is great.
So basically here,
I can see, let's say
Okay, so let's open this toggle.
So, here I have this
habit tracker.
So, if we'll add a new day,
you can see my goals,
basically, but let's add
a new day here.
So I'm adding a new day.
Basically, this is today.
Let's say it should work.
No? Okay. So June 30.
Basically, I'm tracking
I'm tracking a lot of things
during the day.
Today's Wednesday.
Does it become
I mean
So if you do this every day,
does it ever become a burden
to the point where
you just don't feel like doing it
because it's taking
because you just want
to get on with your day?
So it should be frictionless.
And I got to be
honest with Notion,
because of the lack of API,
it's not 100% frictionless,
but it's still very easy to set up.
So every day, when I wake up,
today, I didn't actually do it,
but every day, I'm actually
tracking my goals.
And I'm just putting here
So this is yoga.
- Oh!
This is like
So I have like an AviTrack
and it affects the
actually the day.
So if I'm checking here yoga,
reading, working out,
sleeping well.
And then I have some brain food
that I'm tracking.
So, everything there is.
I'm not tracking food
like everything that I ate.
I'm just tracking things
that I want to -
- Okay.
- It's like a
It's like a white list
of food that I wanna -
Amazing.
That I want to consume every day.
So it's a system.
It's kind of
it becomes a system.
So you see if I'm eating six
different types of food
from this list,
I'm getting this emoji
of avocado here.
Amazing.
You can see it here.
So I know that I
let's say I achieved everything.
So let's say I achieved this one,
and this one, and this one.
- So cool.
And I did this.
So you can see
I'm getting the message,
"Great job, Tommy," automatically.
This is like I'm playing
with the formula of Notion -
And again, this is
all personally for you.
Nobody else sees this.
This is just
for Tommy to feel good.
Yeah.
about the progress you're making.
And one of the things
that Atomic Habits,
and I read the book recently.
One of the things
that he talks about, the author, is
this idea that, obviously,
the incremental 1% improvements
but this idea that you have to do
really small wins every day,
so that you keep on the momentum.
And by seeing these,
all these icons,
and all these emojis,
you actually have that inner
motivation to continue.
But Tommy, we only have -
- Exactly.
We have about six minutes
left and we have
so much to go through.
Yeah.
We have Gyro, we have Calendar,
we have so much to go through.
So let's -
- Sure. Just let me
let me show you
one more thing here
and then we can move
to other aspects
of some you know cool acts
that we can showcase.
But let's talk about
like morning routines.
So, you probably
read a lot of books around
morning routine,
"You should do this,
and this, and this."
So instead of kind of thinking
what is the perfect
morning routine,
you can create a system,
a digital system to actually
do it every day without
thinking about it.
So I have here
you can see this column,
this like sun
kind of sunrise emoji.
So when I open it,
I do several things.
And I built this but I
it's really, really easy to build.
So basically, I can read
an inspirational kind of a
visual image that I love
by Jack Boucher.
I can put here
I can capture
what I'm grateful for.
So I can kind of do
this gratitude kind of practice.
This is the status quo.
So every day, I will see here
a different startup quote
from different
persona that
I love.
Here I do meditations.
So basically,
I have this audio embedded
and I can just take
you know, a step back,
relax, and -
A whole morning routine
on one dashboard, I love it.
Exactly, that idea.
So let's move on to, basically,
this incremental improvement,
so becoming every day better.
So, basically, I built
a system in Notion,
which I can see
and I can reflect for,
probably you
know what is the meaning of
a weekly reflection
or weekly review.
So basically, it's just reflecting
on your week,
planning your next week,
seeing how you
can improve yourself.
So I built a system to do
probably the perfect
weekly review for me.
So here, what I can see
So for each week,
I can see the stuff
that I want to improve.
I'm actually measuring
three main things.
I'm measuring my sleep score,
measuring my productivity score
from RescueTime.
I can show you
the dashboard right away,
and I'm measuring
my health score from Gyroscope.
So basically,
the health score is
This is Gyroscope.
- Oh my god.
- It takes information
from Apple Health,
my Oura ring, the Apple watch.
Many aspects, the weather,
so many things that, you know
RescueTime,
so you can see the focus,
you can see that
on average,
I'm 79 percent focused at work.
So, it kind of aggregates
a lot of information
and present it to you
in a dashboard that,
you know, you can create
correlations between
the different data points.
So let's say I want to know
how my resting heart rate
affects my sleep.
So I can see the details
and I can basically connect
You can see it here.
So you can you can see
my resting heart rate,
which is an indicator
for good health.
And I can connect,
let's say, my computer
stats to see what's going on,
if my heart rate is high,
on the high side,
how does it affect my focus
on the digital space?
You know, I can just explore
some different correlation
between my health and the way
it actually affects
my productivity.
And then you kind of
become your data analysis
or like data scientist
of yourself.
So you kind of,
you know,
you can think about it
You can think about yourself
as a product, as a startup.
The way you optimize
yourself is by data,
and reading data
and affecting on data,
and then optimizing
and thinking how you can
improve yourself every day,
every week, and so on.
Unbelievable. Tommy, talk to me
about calendars.
Talk to me about
what is the importance
of being a good
calendar optimizer and planner.
Yeah, okay. So
So, let's talk a bit
about the future of calendaring.
So what we do at Supertools
So after creating one of the most
biggest productivity communities
in the world, we've decided that we
want to tap into the productivity
SaaS space, and create something
that will be meaningful for
people. So we started to interview
a lot of people.
And we understood that one of them,
the most obsolete, let's say,
tools that we have on
our digital stack is our calendar.
Basically, from 2006, probably,
when Google introduced
Google Calendar,
we haven't seen any innovation
around the most important
time system that we have.
Basically, it's just like,
if I can say,
a stupid record system.
You can record events,
but the software
doesn't make you better.
It doesn't work for you.
You work for your Calendar.
Right.
So one of the most impactful
and useful methodologies
around calendar is time blocking.
Basically, it's a practice
when you block time
on your calendar
and you take and prioritize
tasks that you have
and prioritize goals and put
put some time slots
on your calendar to work on them.
But it's really,
you know,
you have a lot of friction
around it because you need to take
at least an hour of your day
to just do this practice
and it's really hard.
Like honestly, it's really hard.
So as a productivity trainer,
I taught many people
how to do this practice
and to do this workflow,
but I believe a good software
can take a lot of the
a lot of the busy work,
a lot of the hard work.
And basically, what we do now,
we are creating a calendar
that can help you time block,
that can help you be more engaged
with what you want to achieve
and what you want to do.
So you can think
about it as a personal
as a personal kind of assistant
but dedicated
to make you a time machine.
Dedicated to make you a better -
- So give me one or two pointers
about what I should be doing
with my own calendar
What my friends should be doing
with their calendar to be
Yeah.
to get more control
over what we do.
Yeah, and I believe like
the calendar
like the user interface
of the calendar is probably
the most effective thing
that you can use during your day
in order to become
As I come tracking everything
on my calendar
I'm tracking my sleep,
I'm tracking task,
I'm tracking so many things,
and I'm putting everything.
It's like my navigation system.
It work and I just want
to make it better and
I think a lot of people
are waiting to see
a better version of our calendar
but if I can give just one tip
that you can probably implement
from tomorrow until launch
is ask yourself every day,
"What is my most important task?"
and try to book it.
It can be between 60 minutes
to 90 minutes,
try to book it in the first
Right away, after you wake up
and after your morning routine,
try to book it the first thing
in the morning before
you're doing meetings.
Before you're running any meeting,
try to book your
most important task.
Just time to work on it.
You don't have to finish the task.
You just need to be accountable
to the time, and you know, exactly
like you're accountable
to a meeting with your doctor.
So think you have a meeting
with your doctor
like you're just
working on your
most important task.
So, it really helps you
prioritize and kind of take
intentions into actions.
Turn intention into actions.
And this is why I love
time blocking because
it's so effective.
You feel the change right away.
And obviously,
one of the most difficult
challenges with this
is that you are
You're the only attendee
of your calendar invite.
So when something else
pops up or when somebody
needs your attention,
it's much easier to tell yourself,
"Oh, Michael, yeah,
I'll just get to this later."
Yeah.
So I'll give you another tip.
So this is what we can do
together, maybe.
So I am
accountability partner.
All right.
And let's say you have a task,
and I have a task,
I can send you a Zoom invite
to, let's say, 90 minutes
of focus time.
Okay? So we can be
focused together.
We are muting the call.
You work on your most important task,
I work on my most important task.
And we are catching up every
like 30 minutes to just check in
what's going on.
Accountability partner is
it's probably one of the most
effective things that you can do
for your product to supercharge
your productivity.
So, if you are working from home,
this can be really,
really effective.
And you don't need any tool.
You can just send -
- Exactly.
a calendar invite to your partner
and work on your most, yeah.
We're doing it a lot.
We also have a clock here.
This is really cool.
So, basically, we created
the Zoom background when
- I'll show you.
- Oh, that's so cool.
Yeah. So we have sort of
like a Pomodoro clock.
So every
So we are
We are working with intervals
It's called Pomodoro.
So every time,
everyone can see this clock.
Everyone are working
on their s**t
and by the end of the session,
we are just checking in,
going to take coffee,
to the restroom,
and continuing
with the next session.
So it can be really effective
and really, Oh sorry.
[laughs]
Yeah.
This is like a big time saver.
So, for long webinars,
this can be really effective.
So, if you want to go and still
be engaged with the meeting,
you can create your own avatar.
Tommy, show me the one
of your living room. Yeah.
- Wait, no, no, the -
- The living room?
Oh, this one.
Oh, this one, yes,
like when you have
this annoying person
who is getting into the frame
[laughs]
I love it. I love it.
Yeah basically
you could do a lot of stuff.
Yeah.
Tommy
This is my favorite movie.
It's also effective
to put the agenda
of the meeting here.
This one is for eBay but
Amazing.
Yeah, many cool stuff. So
Wow. Amazing, amazing, amazing.
Tommy, this is just fascinating.
And you know, it very shows
that this is something that you're
so passionate about.
And obviously, the things
you showed here
are things that you've been
working on for quite some time.
And while there may be
a lot of friction to get into them
on day one, on day two. The goal is
for them to be a frictionless
part of your day, and actually,
just make you that 1%
more productive.
So I'm sure that by now,
you don't feel that it's a chore
to go on, and you know,
continue managing them.
They're already set in place.
And one of the things that
I'm making a goal for myself is
to set some of these things
up for me because
I hold myself accountable
to many things.
I don't yet hold myself
accountable for my sleep
or for how productive
I am throughout the day.
And I definitely feel
like I'm chasing my own calendar.
I'm chasing the things
that I have to do
instead of taking
ownership over them.
So thank you for the inspiration.
Before we leave, Tommy,
I need three words that you
would use to describe yourself.
Well, building time machines,
probably
Yeah, it's like the perfect way
to describe what I'm doing
and what is my long-term vision
40 years from now.
So I'll always build
like time machines
and make them more accessible
and want to democratize
productivity to the rest
of the world.
I love it. Tommy, toda raba.
Thank you very, very much.
And I can't wait to -
- It was fun
Can't wait to catch up
properly in Israel.
Me, too, man. Bye-bye.